In your seminar there, you was given on this, are you saying it might get out of that that a little bit of sun is okay and that therapy through hormone therapy is such a bad thing if done right.
So is a little bit of two different questions is sunshine good for you?
Absolutely. Sunshine is wonderful for you is getting sun burned good for you. No, that's not good for you is using sunscreen good for you. No, that's not good for you either.
So next week I'm not going to be here. I'm going to go to Hawaii.
So hopefully Lord willing and when I go out the sun, I do not use sunscreen.
Now I have maybe what would be considered black Irish skin and I don't burn really easy if I'm careful if I cover up and but some people have very Norwegian skin and they burn really easy and they cannot go out in the sun without just burning.
No matter what those are the people that would be who've them to get a natural sunscreen you can buy it over the counter at Amazon some from some natural house. There's many recipes that you can make your own as well. My daughter makes your own natural sunscreen.
But sunshine is good for you getting sun burned repeatedly can lead to skin cancers but the sun does not cause skin cancer.
So the sun is your source of vitamin D and is beneficial for a whole bunch of reasons that we can talk for an hour on.
Second question is is hormone therapy are you talking about the Lupron therapy?
Like not that I know some women have had compounded.
But the biological bioidentical hormone replacement therapy, a good thing or a bad thing.
So one of my fellowships is in functional and anti-aging medicine and that whole group is really big into bioidentical hormones.
Now because my specialty is cancer, I don't really adhere to a lot of things that they would adhere to.
They're doing bioidentical hormones to help a person feel younger, longer, there could be arguments that that could be very beneficial.
Now if done right, I don't think it increases one's risk for cancer, but you have to stay well monitored.
So a woman who's like going through horrible metaposal symptoms and goes on a bioidentical hormone replacement therapy approach.
And it's done correctly. I don't think that increases their cancer risk.
If you go on standard hormone replacement therapy, it highly increases your cancer risk because they're not using bioidentical hormones.
Right on the packaging, Google this if you need to, it gives you a 10 times risk for hormone cancers.
Especially if you have some specific genetic predispositions. So if you have tumor suppressor genes in defects in certain tumor suppressor genes, you should not be doing hormone replacement therapy as a woman.
So there's other ways that you can help yourself get through metaposal, particularly in a way I'm subject here, but a person that goes through metaposal has a lot of symptoms going through metaposal, then you know, so normally your ovaries decreased progesterone and estrogen production.
That's what metaposal is.
Now, your adrenal glands also make estrogen and progesterone. And if a woman has healthy adrenal glands, that's the woman who says, oh, I went through metaposal, I didn't have any problems.
I don't know what your problem is. And then woman B is like, I go through metaposal, I got hot flashes, I feel like crap. I don't know what's wrong with me.
Well, that's the person who has adrenal issues. So by supporting adredals and by naturally using things like chase tree and maca root, there's a bunch of different herbs that can be really beneficial to help a woman go through metaposal without having all these hot flashes, you could not only not increase their cancer risk, but you can help them balance out those hormones through that.
So I have never been really a fan of bioidentical hormone replacement therapy, just because I just don't know if there's enough studies that that is real safe.
But it's been going on for about 20 years now, and there really isn't any any proof that it increases cancer risk if it's done correctly. So I kind of change my view that it's not really wrong if it's done correctly.
So hopefully that answers your question.